Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of time
on this, but I have an example for you of what
happens when you confront one of these right
wing Republicans who repeats fake stories.
One such fake story is schools are putting
litter boxes in the bathrooms so that students
who identify as animals can use the litter
box as their bathroom. It's made up. Didn't
happen. It has been repeated and repeated and
repeated, but it did not happen. Donald Bolduc,
who's running in New Hampshire, was confronted
about it. Why did you say that? That's just not
true. And he says, Well, it's what I was told.
Speaker 3: You made at a recent event.
Speaker 1: About.
Speaker 5: Children using litter boxes
in schools. You know, there's there's. Oh, that's
not what I said. Okay, well, then tell me what you
said. I heard the audio. So what? Yeah. So what I
was talking about is all the craziness going on in
our schools, and this is just one of them. And I
had a I had a parent and a student in the audience
who came up to me and told me all about it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, guys, listen. A parent and
a student. If it was only a parent,
okay? If it was only a student,
but a parent and a student told them, students
who identify as animals are going poop and poo
poo in a litter box. So he started repeating it.
Speaker 5: I've heard that all across the state,
so I'm only articulating what
I heard from his parents.
Speaker 1: He didn't make it up. He heard it.
Speaker 5: Guys, children.
Craziness is going on in our schools. Senator
Hanson is responsible for it. She's doubled down
on all the bad education policies out there.
Speaker 1: Understand how crazy this is?
It's not happening in schools.
And Maggie Hassan has nothing
to do with it because it's not taking place.
Speaker 5: So you should be asking her why our
children can't read and write the grade level, why
we have the lowest scores, why we can't compete
in the world, why our children require remedial
courses to go to college. Because she has took
our eye off the ball on the future of our nation,
and that's our children. You had a parent tell
you. Yes. That this happened in school, happening
in the school. The school has come out and said
that that's completely false. Well, you know, they
came out and said they didn't have children. They
came out and said they didn't do a lot of things
right. They don't teach CRT, which they do. They
don't teach children transgender, which they do.
Speaker 1: They teach transgender.
Speaker 5: I'm not backing down. Okay.
Speaker 1: He's not backing down from something
that is just not happening. And so you can Google
this. It's widely documented. There's a good NBC
News article from a couple of weeks ago how an
urban myth about litter boxes in schools became a
Republican talking point. At least 20 Republicans
claimed schools are making accommodations
for students who identify as cats. The school
districts say these claims are untrue. We would
be able to write this off as an insanely stupid
timeline if people weren't falling for it and
if people weren't actually being influenced in
their votes based on these bogus false stories.
Really scary stuff. Make sure you're following
us on Instagram at David Pakman show. To
see all of the clips that we played today